ja oder nein neuen video ich habe heute
den lieben roman loch war dabei und
heiko lockt man natürlich auf die lucy
soja ist genau doch jedoch hebt diese
vorlieben alex locken ausverkauft
das war unser geld und wäre auf jeden
fall haben wir uns für heute überlegt
wir machen mal dieses youtuber
körperteile erraten bzw erste von
youtube
das langt es spart was weder vor wir
haben es wieder zwei erster aus der
sucht ja er und ich und war männlich und
von weiblichen youtuber natürlich und
ich würde sagen viel aber gar nicht
lange und die beiden natürlich auf ihrem
zettel auch wieder gemacht mit mir
deswegen schaut er am ende vorbei als er
hat ja natürlich wir fangen jetzt anfang
an gut denn los geht also ich hab ich
hier den ersten arsch freunde dann
schaut euch mal diese nach frankreich
und sagte danach problem ass ganz dieser
art ist ja wirklich daran dass zuvor ja
wahrscheinlich besten arsch ist das hier
wimmelt dieser art ist das was ich sage
ist der bericht aber auch das ist der
prinz locker dass der prinz das ist der
prinz sicher wird er ganz sicher hat
sich ja immer noch
schließlich gab es über den zukünftigen
andere wie machst du das ich kann das
gar nicht fassen das ist einfach schon
an zu machen sagt kannst du so übergaben
jetzt bist du doch nicht nur bin ich mir
einfach dass der alex hat auch vor dem
videodreh schon angetippt dass er die
besten lustigsten krassesten erreichen
prozent auf den sonst ist das alles
müsste ich ja ok macht erkennen wir
sicher sind
arien kennt den drei jetzt hatte ich
doch nicht dort ist wo ich bin völlig
und sagst du ich bin ich als ganz sicher
ganz sicher ist sich da ein bisschen ich
bin so ein junger lotse heute oder was
was leute hierher darauf dass das
magazin wie lange ist das schon her dass
ihr das soll ja so
ja aber bewusst gemacht dass integration
er ja das ist schon eher doch dann
kriegen wir uns von deinen arsch von
einer weiblichen person ich hatten wir
werden das dann von der deutschen
youtube ist es ein gesicht und zudem hat
das am ende hätten bisher ja das frage
ich mich auch das wahlvolk stadt sind
hier ist wird so sind doch natürlich
machst du das selbst nicht sagte jetzt
hat der kreis erwartet man menschen es
ist darum jetzt okay so also das ist
auch ganz einfach nie das wusste ich
sofort das ist dieser hielt das müsst
ihr so wollt oder nicht das ist das
wirklich nicht schwer
ja ja als ich nach dieser coolen kleines
highlight auf das wir so klar dass man
so lange überlegen
jetzt ist euch jetzt entscheidet ist
kaffee ach so ich sage dann was ist mit
den fans was du für dich immer parat
vielleicht mit seinem langen und er bei
dir
okay das habe ich für ein gewinnertyp
diese personen waren hatten ab geht's
wieder mitgespielt
dann ist nämlich meinen also mal keine
antwort der russische abgesagt
was das denn der hat noch einen tipp
merzig ist sozusagen mit der anderen
youtube picasa hey wir brauchen ab
geht's video nein ihre keine ahnung wer
da drin jahren habe ich erwarte dass wir
uns überlegen
drei mal okay das auch wissen was melina
war das stimmt sind dass im hintergrund
für das ist umso haben gewartet doch mal
man kann nicht weiter suchen ich habe
auch gar nicht vorgesehen sagte der ok
betroffener kennt das ist der traum
irgendwo gemacht werden so einfach dahin
gestellt
damit das nicht gehört becker ich habe
gehört du nicht gewinnen wird es gewiss
geholt
jetzt kommt das beste geschäftsjahr in
zwei prozent
wer ist das auf jeden fall mit mike
singer oder er ist voll schwer ich
dachte eigentlich geplant deshalb hätten
schreibt das ist doch ein arrangement da
hier der ist schwarz alberto ist sein
letzter als erste dass darwin der kirche
das ist nicht abwertend sonst sagen dass
insgesamt der youtuber seinen youtube er
hat über 500.000 doch nach einigen dann
bist du trägst
das ist natürlich ein klares foul
hast du denn ich habe da nicht halt ich
habe eigentlich die mit mit den fans
gerecht wie ein bisschen stressig reist
energie etwas sorgen was machen ich weiß
genau was ja heute das war es jetzt
erstmal mit dem video wird euch der ein
oder andere art richtig gefallen dann
zeigt will und dann sogar zu ihr sagen
ich musste das immer sehr zusetzt hier
hilft mir kraft zu hertha haben einfach
daher ist meine partner haben den geist
was sie doch mehr studios guten jetzt
alter alters ist wohl nur dass sie
gefahren
wahlweise kann das wird im video fans
gefallen hat dann hat sich gefallen
schaut auch auf jeden fall bei den
beiden auf dem kanal vorbei ist
natürlich in der video beschreibung
ganze um verlinkt
und ja ins netz stellen will wir sehen
uns am nächsten sonntag wieder auf ihrer
nächsten freitag